E aí
[Aplausos]
se você nunca sua história está
encontradas botões do fogão pequeno a
noite toda durante as estações aperto de
mão estranhos familiares em barbearias e
salões em capas e sobre os ombros de
áreas em salas de estar e sala de aulas
onde os pequenos os americanos a cair e
seus sonhos em casos de cópias impressas
dentro de cada folha para pesquisa a
simplesmente para a contar histórias o
que está não é unicamente nomes para te
ver os homens os olhos de nossos
antepassados e entre línguas de nossos
vizinhos Esses são artigos diferentes
passar de geração em geração se são
certas descrições legais e
o Samuel Martins Sao joac sangue Armadas
e utiliza o silêncio cês são bibliotecas
de tags teatro essencial durações
casamentos e festas procissão e nos
muito singles em funerais dos é complexo
e deve se ele tem sido muitas plantinhas
dizer onde estamos e onde vamos não
estamos nos comentários nós somos feia
não Funda sem quem me siga samba duro é
muito mais usamos os pais de sua
história para nos ver e materiais nos
como esses produtos não está nos seus
histórias
eu quero precisamos longos Nossa amiga
só madeira Rosa flores e complete os
nossos dizer que você brinca nosso amor
pedir ninguém